[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this
is your update about the
coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Now, a few of you
asked in the comments
of last week's update, Timothy,
why do you look so tired?
Well, it might be
because Google I/O
is in just about three weeks.
Three weeks!
OK, if you're as excited as I
am, this first link is for you.
You can now start planning
your Google I/O 2016 schedule.
Yay!
Just head on over to the link
in the description below.
Tilt Brush is a new
app that enables
artists to use virtual
reality to paint the 3D
space around them.
Trust me, it's awesome.
But it can be difficult
to describe how it feels
without trying it firsthand.
Today we bring you
a little closer
in a new Chrome experiment
titled Virtual Art Sessions.
Follow the link below to observe
six world-renowned artists
as they develop blank canvases
into beautiful works of art.
Each session can be
explored from start
to finish from any
angle, including
the artist's perspective.
All viewable, right
from the browser.
Recordings of over 30
sessions from GCP Next
are now up on YouTube.
They're all awesome.
But if you're wondering
where you should start,
try this list of the
top five, linked below.
Building for round
screens with Android Wear
just got a lot easier.
With Android Wear API 23, we
introduced a new round resource
identifier, which helps
you separate resource
files between round
and square devices.
Get all the details on the post.
Also on Android
Wear, if your app
is using BIND_LISTENER intent
filters in your manifest,
you should know that this
API has been deprecated
on all Android versions.
The new replacement
API introduced
in Google Play
Services 8.2 is more
efficient for Android devices.
You should migrate
to this as soon
as possible to ensure
the best user experience.
All the details are in-- you
got it-- the post linked below.
The latest version of Chrome
supports the Credential
Management API.
It's a standards-track
proposal at the W3C that
gives developers programmatic
access to a browser's
credential manager and helps
users sign in more easily.
To learn more and get started
integrating it into your site,
jump to the link below.
And that's your
update for the week.
Remember to click on
all the links below.
Oh, and with I/O
getting so close,
make sure to use the
hashtag #AskDevShow
to let us know who
you'd like me to talk to
and what questions to ask.
We'll try to add
them to the lineup.
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]